-Welcome back,
and thank you for being here,
thank you for watching.
Today is Friday,
and that's usually when I catch
up with some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was just running
a bit behind --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was running
a bit behind today,
and so I thought
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out my weekly
thank-you notes right now.
Is that cool with you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing note music, please?
♪♪
Wow.
-Oh, he blinked.
-He's got -- Yeah.
-That's to show he's not wax.
[ Laughter ]
-He's not waxed?
-He's not made of wax.
-Oh.
-You didn't know it --
-I thought you were
talking about --
I thought you were saying
that he wasn't manscaping.
-Oh, no, he's manscaped.
He's totally manscaped.
[ Laughter ]
He's got the whole thing,
a razor kit --
you don't want to know about it.
-Yeah, I see he posted
"vaxed and waxed."
-"VaxedAndWaxed"
is his Instagram account.
-Yeah.
I didn't open the photo.
-Yeah, don't.
Don't look it up
on the Internet, either.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, the White House,
for sending everyone
high-quality masks
that most people will still wear
on their chin.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Coachella poster,
for looking like
a musical eyesight exam.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Harry Po-- Harry styles.
Harry Styles?
[ Laughter ]
-Can't tell.
-No, I can't tell
who's on earlier in the day.
Death by Voguing?
Is that a band?
-Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
Everybody's equal.
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-At Coachella,
everybody's equal.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, all the same
9-point font.
-They're all equal?
-Yeah.
-So they get paid --
Death by Vogue
gets the same paycheck
as Harry Styles?
-Oh, no, no, no.
-Oh, hell no.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
-All right, back to work.
-Back to work.
No more goofing around.
-Yeah, quit goofing around.
Just get back to work.
-What's that?
-I said quit goofing around...
-Yeah.
-...and get back to work.
-Back to work.
-Yeah.
-Got to be done.
-Gotta work!
-What? Work.
♪ And work, and work ♪
-And work -- yeah.
-♪ Ber-be-der-be-der, work ♪
♪♪
♪ Da-da-dun, da-da-dun,
and work ♪
♪ And work ♪
♪ Come on, now,
let's dance on it, work ♪
♪ Work ♪
♪ Come on, now, workin' ♪
♪ Car ♪
♪ Get you car washed today ♪
♪ Fill up,
and you don't have to pay ♪
♪ Come on, na, na, na ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
-♪ Working at the car wash ♪
♪ Working at the car wash,
yeah ♪
-That's a jam, man.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's my jam.
-Yeah.
-A banger.
♪♪
Thank you, "abcdefu,"
for being a great breakup song,
and also the reason
the preschool called
to schedule a parent/teacher
conference.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Blah-blah-blah-blah-blah.
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, dentist appointment,
for beginning
with a quick Q and A
where all my answers are lies.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, you've been flossing?
-Floss?
Yeah, twice a day, I floss.
-Four or five times a day.
-Are you kidding me, man?
I can't stop flossing.
Love that stuff.
-They call me Mr. Floss.
-So fun to floss.
-I love it.
-Are you kidding me?
-Six times a day --
-They call me Mr. Floss at work.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, soy sauce packets,
for guaranteeing
I get three drops on my food
and 500 drops on my shirt.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, zinc lozenges.
You may not shorten my cold,
but at least
you make my mouth feel
like I sucked on a roll
of dirty nickles.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I think it's helping me?
♪♪
Thank you, salad spinners,
for being a teacup ride
for lettuce.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our thank-you notes.